what an incredible hour with jerry west
marshall faulk what an incredible
privilege to have jerry west here's
gonna set this is a good day it's a Hall
of Fame central day leave a Hall of
Famer in Jerry West we have a Hall of
Famer and Ed Reed calling in we've a
Hall of Famer at Marshall Faulk I'm
Susie Schuster I'm a Hall of Famer in my
own eyes and then we have another Hall
of Famer in lessening Howe aisle
referred to as mr. Kara Henderson so we
want to thank les need from the LA Rams
coming into the studio you're not even
you're not even smiling at that no
that's it I think that's it that's a
holiday that's a whole theme response to
your wife by the way oh no doubt so we
know who runs this anyhow Faye might get
into it's because of her yeah there's no
doubt now I am and I'm n the Wiregrass
Hall of Fame you are yeah google that
and see if you can find it anyway it's a
little part of pocket of Alabama uh-huh
like let's call it the south east corner
of Alabama the Wiregrass so okay that's
probably listen man you make any Hall of
Fame count I'm just saying but you look
really Wiregrass I mean it's I yeah I
had not heard of that I'm from the south
there has been some good football
players from the wire there you go
tell us yes give us some names good I'm
trying to let me see if I can think of
the best last name ball here's a good
one Marshall and this is he's actually
from my hometown guy named Walter Reeves
Walter okay that's probably before your
time and he basically played a decade
probably with the Arizona Cardinals
tight in you know why bring up Walter
East in those days best blocking tight
in but do you know what he did the guy
named Frank Thomas couldn't beat him out
in football so he decided I'm gonna go
focus on baseball well now I'm not sure
that's why Frank ended up playing
baseball but I do know this Frank backed
up Walter Reeves at all but I remember
him didn't he play from like 88 to 96
right dawn I remember him by the way
I've got Don Bowie talking in my ear
don't I sound like you really know what
I'm talking about
mr. Walter Reeves he did that's a good
amen look if you finish that they'll
find it you have to use it any kind of
hall-of-fame you can possibly use you
got a Hall of Fame this is what I do the
bride's all ready this is the Brian
couple transition that's when you take
off your glasses you look down and look
over and that's when you transition so
this is when I say well so last night
the the San Francisco 49ers now ain't no
in the season you know what that feels
like from last year as they are atop the
NFC West what are your thoughts on that
team that you stopped playing last night
I interestingly right it probably
selfishly need needed to pull against
them
so because of Halloween I remember it
being seven nothing Arizona got into by
week some Halloween stuff picked up the
game saw though it was it was a nice fun
finish definitely would like to see
Arizona get the ball back but I've been
impressed would San Francisco even even
the previous two years when there had
quarterback injuries and they they were
a very very tough out with with whether
as Nick Mullens or CJ better so you
you've seen this group building over the
last two years and and knew if if they
get the QB things stabilized added some
pieces on defense what you like about
what they did is they stayed the course
they believed in what they were doing
and last year maybe defense was a
problem for them now it's a strength for
them based on developing players they
drafted and then added and a few
veterans key places talked about the
complexities of being a GM in today's
league you guys make moves you you bring
guys in you make trades you you know it
it's always moving you don't you you
really don't just get to hunker down and
say this is our team well what's so
different nowaday then say you know five
ten years ago you it's a GM right we're
always thinking short term long term but
if we answered that question you go when
I first got into the league as a
tree-level whatever right picking up
anyone from the airport that we brought
in in Jax for me and in those days with
the Jacksonville Jaguars it was an
expansion team so it seems like we
brought in new people every single week
so that was an interesting job but free
agency adjustable and had just began
then so and in those days it was new so
we actually I remember we've got we got
price pop we got Lian Circe we are
really good players from other teams and
they were UFAs in their contract expired
and they came to Jacksonville then you
saw where team said you know what we're
gonna keep our core players a little bit
harder four pillars of other teams to
get the free agency weather would the
franchise tag or would you know redoing
contracts early I do think the advent of
the when they when we went with the new
rookie compensation system in the last
CBA where there was a time when teams
didn't want to pick early in the draft
Maidstone you were picking an unknown
player that obviously had potential to
develop into a really good player but
wasn't there yet but you were paying
that player as one of your probably top
one two three or four or fifth player on
your team based on where he was drafted
so I think eliminating that aspect of
the compensation for rookies allowed you
know teams more willing to you know
trade wanna trade for early picks and
things like that so there's a lot of
variables like anything I think as I was
sitting backstage jerry west mention it
right the games whether it's basketball
football soccer baseball it's changing
and involving rapidly how about how
about how you evaluate in the first
round if you're picking one through ten
you look at it a certain way
how about when you're you're picking on
the back end you know you have those
last five six seven picks are the first
realm do you evaluate it as a do you
look at it as first round
learn or is it how do you how do you
evaluate it I think in I here's here's
how we do it I do think there's a subset
of players each year probably depending
and it's all based on when they were
born and when they when they choose to
come out of school whether it's as a
redshirt sophomore true junior are
staying their senior senior year there
is this in each draft whether it's 5 10
12 there's there's a subset of number of
players who may be physically just more
gifted than the rest again that number
changes every year again based probably
on who was born when and when he decided
to come out to school I do think what we
have found late first middle the first
late somewhere in there depending on the
year in the draft that if you let your
mathematicians and your analysts really
you know regress analysis and study
those players probably are very similar
to players you can get in the second
round as well so in each year it may be
it may be 30 guys we're picked 20
through 50 or very similar in in mom dad
god-given ability and all of them are
gonna be good football players and and
then and then there's a little bit of a
clifton mate but you're seeing i would
say this i just sum it all up late 1st
2nd round even into the third some good
football players come out of those
rounds and that's last year while when
we had a first round pick uh-huh we may
have had three picks two or three picks
in the top 100 our strategy was if we
could move back from our late
first-round pick and keep moving back so
that we could end up with maybe five
picks in the top 100 instead of two when
you this is that and i've been i've been
contemplating this i speak on it from an
example is it harder to GM
once you've given a quarterback that
hundred plus million compared to
beforehand we're just starting that so
I'll be able to answer that better in a
couple of years here's the the positive
of it is as a franchise you've found a
QB that you feel like can lead your
franchise that Pat position and I try to
stay away from franchise cubies and what
here they are but that that person that
position is very important to figure out
for the short and long term so the
positive is you've obviously found that
and also the positive is once you do
that contract that's an anchor point so
it does help you manage the future a
little bit easier in that you know how
much money you have in that position now
you have to figure out where you're
going to allocate the other resources
and that's based on position but more
importantly based on I call it the human
beings playing that position right
always I like to say it in our building
the positions are really just two
letters in the alphabet right mm-hm
Arby's just two letters but if you're
running back is Marshall Faulk and he
threatens the opposing defense opposing
defenses are trying to figure out each
week how to stop you whether it's
running catching and you're scoring
touchdowns
you know what Marshall Faulk bat
position is the pillar of our team and
we need to make sure we keep that person
long term so that's that's the positive
okay in the QB let's knead here on the
Rich Eisen show alongside Marshall Faulk
I'm Susie Schuster let's talk about
Darrell Henderson no relation of course
that you drafted led the team with
carries 11 yards 20 carries against the
Bengals and London how are you seeing
him develop I think the last couple
games last three weeks he he has played
more so anytime you the game is starting
to slow down for him you know and that's
just natural core so I think we'll see
more more
or of him and you know both running the
football and catching the football but
what we do know is when he does have
space he's proven to be an explosive
player he can break tackles and he can
he can gain yards at a you know a fast
rate and it's a it's important in
today's league to have two guys that you
can count on in the back for you
stopping that when I played it was like
if you were to back you or the back I
can remember Mike marks will call
timeouts if I came out of the game and
it was an important situation but in
today's league it is it is it's huge you
have to have multiple guys back there
who can who can get it done oh yeah and
I think they're the hey different
flavors back there also and sometimes
when you call it change of pace can't
definitely you know defense can prepare
for one player and then we've always
seen the right nicknames thunder and
lightning when when there's these
dynamic duo's that that you know earn
those nicknames based on their play but
I think the different styles of whatever
the runner brings in his style of play
definitely can help as well how about
how about a young guy that surprised you
young guy surprised you I think in let's
just take that you are you one of our
youngest from this year's draft class
Dave Edwards at a Wisconsin and and he
was very impressive from the beginning
again a Wisconsin Lyman comes in knowing
how to play the game verbage is very
similar so your NFL PlayBook is is not
far and it you know it's not a spread
system there but he was you know he was
a right tackle at Wisconsin actually
went there high school QB tied in to to
right tackle up because of Jo note
wounds injury we inserted him in is that
you know starting left guard for the
last two weeks and in in those two weeks
we've played Grady Jared Geno Acton's
he's had to go against and has performed
admirably so I'll give I'll get it
that's a nice berry lettuce
prizes fifth round pick interestingly
probably in one of the Mel Kiper Todd
McShea 'he's way too early
mock drafts that comes out probably the
day after the draft for next year there
was probably three offensive linemen
from Wisconsin that were in the first
round he was one of them but did play
his his last year at Wisconsin with an
injury so there's a didn't play as well
so that affected his draft stock I put
on my glasses I shortchanged gerald
Henderson that happens shipped it back
down well you know it's interesting
y'all know Kara well she's very smart
very witty she's at home right now
saying no no yes she did taste but nice
I know her tweet uh-huh
and I think it was based on the the
Newhart show like something to do this
is my brother Darryl and Darryl Brothers
Darryl's so whatever her tweet with I
mean you know artist Harmon so our
director of PR yeah he was he was going
no way no don't you can't do it artist
very conservative probably hasn't
totally evolved to the new you know lay
culture you know whatever goes on in
that Twitter space but it was it was
very witty dynamic tweet that he cut up
I went to Columbia there's no math
requirement and never talk numbers I
mean I oughta just like stay in my lane
I'm like realizing that's why I got it
yeah a recommendation from Bob Kraft to
but that that's that's another story
so nobody goes to jail there's a lot
there let's talk about the acquisition
of jail and Ramsey and trading away I
can't believe that was low-hanging fruit
fire less yeah this is there's parts
that you come back here this is a fun
show there's there's parts of your job
that people don't understand so I just
wanted to get into like what you have to
go through mentally to be a general
manager people just think you like this
is the team that's it like there's a lot
that goes into the work that you guys
have to do
and I mean the Jalen Ramsey trade it's
just that that was me it's a pivot you
have a need and there's a guy out there
that can make your team better you know
that's that was in also and this is what
you we deal with his general managers
and and I what's required in the job we
did know coming into this year that okay
we we have a situation at corner where
we've got two players that are you know
gonna they're in the final year their
contract so you're always you're not
just waiting til the end of the season
to see how it goes and whether you
resign them or not to to figure that out
so last year when we drafted David long
in the third round we did realize
there's probably gonna be a corner from
last year's draft based on how how good
it was probably in the front seven it
was gonna push corners back and I forget
where that when the first corner got
drafted but it was probably in the late
20s which normally doesn't happen in the
draft so and when we another player that
is starting for us is Darryl Williams I
mean at about Darius Williams out of UAB
we had liked him in the previous draft
he made Baltimore's team was cut last
year and we claimed him but we were
always trying to add these young
talented corners in preparation for what
might happen at our corner position but
with Jalen Ramsey he was will never
discussed right no one's the
Jacksonville Jaguars is not trading
Jalen Ramsey but all of a sudden there
is an opportunity there like wait a
minute
Jalen ramsley is possibly available
should-should the rams
you know take advantage of this
opportunity so you're always having to
adjust when new opportunities that
you're not planning for or off for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app